just to warn you that this report coming
up from our U.S correspondent Martha
Kellner includes flash photography and
offensive comments
Kanye West has built a career on being a
provocateur
but he has now found the limit of what
is acceptable and far beyond that a
barrage of anti-Semitic tirades in
recent weeks have made one of the music
industry's most successful artists a
pariah in his own Parish
on a podcast overnight he was peddling
this tired old Trope there's been times
where I had my lawyer was Jewish my
regular was Jewish but like like eight
people that basically would collude and
talk without me were in groups saying
okay this is what the tour is going to
be this is his next house and they were
making all these decisions and they're
making all this money West's hate speech
comes amid a rise in anti-semitic
incidents in America this was a protest
by Nazis in Los Angeles over the weekend
Kanye is right when Banner says and Sky
News has obtained this video of a group
under the cover of Darkness Distributing
anti-semitic leaflets in an LA
neighborhood a few of them landed on Sam
and Leia yebrey's doorstep they spew
horrible anti-semitic conspiracy
theories about Jews being behind covid
or the lgbtq movement or controlling
president Trump do you feel like Kanye
West Has emboldened This Racist hate
speech week he's a walking billboard for
for this hate I mean the billboard did
say Kanye's right so you have to connect
the dots imagine being someone who's
been trafficking and anti-Semitism for
years and now one of the biggest
celebrities in the entire world uh
validates your ideas uh this is this is
a boon for the haters and the bigots out
there
West has now been dropped by his
sponsors dismissed by social media
platforms and disavowed by celebrity
friends his ex-wife Kim Kardashian
writing hate speech is never okay or
excusable and calling for hateful
rhetoric against the Jewish Community to
come to an end
Adidas were under enormous pressure to
terminate their partnership with Kanye
West and they have now done so they say
it will cost them almost 250 million
dollars Financial experts predict it
will cost West over 1 billion dollars
in a statement Adidas said yay's recent
comments and actions have been
unacceptable hateful and dangerous and
they violate the company's values of
diversity and inclusion mutual respect
and fairness
Kanye West has decimated his reputation
and taken a sledgehammer to his fortune
even more damaging he's Amplified lies
which Jewish people have battled for
decades and from that his name may never
recover Martha Kellner Sky News Los
Angeles